so how long have you been preparing this
particular store for
this room I set up at the start of this
year so uh just coming up on 12 months
really
Barry hopes for the best but is
preparing for the worst how much food do
you have here well my goal now is to
have enough food for three of us for six
months that's that's my goal because you
just don't know Barry is a prepper
someone that builds a stockpile because
they see a major crisis ahead the the
cost of living crisis power outage is
fuel shortages
those things I'm well prepared for now
five years ago for the story there was
going to be a huge war in Europe and a
global pandemic would you believe it
make no mistake those things will happen
again and I'd just rather be ready
Barry's asked us not to show his
identity and I in fact it's something
that quite a few of the Preppers we've
spoken to for this report have asked of
us and it's not because they're
embarrassed about what they do it's that
if there is a crisis they don't want
people to know where they live who they
are and how much they have
because some Preppers believe a big
crisis could lead to civil unrest
Barry's air guns are just a hobby but
he's ready for a breakdown of Law and
Order
I feel confident that me and my sons
could protect our home if we needed to
ever got to that point yeah do you think
it would get to that point though
I don't think it takes a lot for people
to get crazy it really doesn't
prepping as a movement started in the
United States but as the UK heads into a
winter of warnings about power
disruption it's something more people
here are doing from a base in rural
Wales Lee price sells prepper Goods
survival kits long-term food rations
he's never been busier it's the what ifs
what if the electric goes off what if um
I can't get heating or whatever whatever
it is so it's it's planning ahead that's
all it is really
and have you noticed more and more
people are doing that oh yeah yeah and
from every Walk of Life yeah what do you
mean by that every Walk of Life well we
have people following up you know there
could be doctors or teachers you know
from cities from the country any
anywhere really they've always had this
perception of tin out wearing nut jobs
you know but they're not you know
they're just people who like to make
sure they've got a bit of security at
home
and that security can bring reassurance
when things feel unpredictable life has
got a little bit more uncertain and when
we sort of lack that control we can
become anxious so doing a little bit of
prepping actually gives you a little bit
of control back you're actually making
proactive decisions that can help you
when things go horribly wrong
Preppers say this isn't Panic buying
it's not paranoia it's being ready for
the future in uncertain times
Catherine if I don't see Sky News